[Music]
what's up alex
hey dudes ken how are you we're doing
great man what's up
so
i kind of have like a part i guess
student loan and retirement questions so
uh i was
as they said i was dumb and i went to
out of state school and um i let my
folks handle a lot of the
student loan stuff and borrowed
more than i needed so
um
so yeah long story short i paid off the
loans in my name to the point where my
employer will pick up
um the payments the minimum payments and
then the big one is the payment plus
loans that i'm also paying on um
uh that right now i got it down to 150
150 000. wow um
so your parents took out parent plus
loans but you've agreed morally to pay
them
yes you're not legally obligated but you
you that's the deal between you and your
mom and dad
yes okay and your student loans are all
gone
uh all except for eight thousand but my
employer they're paying um a certain
amount per month on it what's your
degree in
the
account what do you make
uh right now make 80. how old are you
24. master's degree in accounting
no uh i decided to go to community
college for the 153rd so i was smart
with that i decided not to uh build a
master's degree
you went to a community college for 150
000 in student loans debt on a parent
plus loan no
no no no no so i went to uh
an out of state college four year
um
so most of all
what is it 180 ended up being for the my
four years and then
i just cash flowed 2000 for community
college
because for accounting you need 30 extra
credits so i just did a community
college instead of masters
oh i see what you're doing okay yeah
you're talking about credit you're
talking about getting your cpa okay
all right okay okay okay okay so you're
24 and you're making 80 grand
all right yeah well you got 150 to go
okay
my question was like i wasn't sure like
if since it's not in my name oh yeah
it's in your name you shook your daddy's
hand
all right
yeah yeah this is your you took on this
debt you're you claimed this debt i
heard you a minute ago
yeah i don't care if the law doesn't say
you owe it but the law of the of your
household says you owed it because
you're a man and you gave your word
yes that's yeah so you're going to pay
it down but you're going to treat it
like you're dead because it is your debt
the technicality of the legal
technicality don't get you out of it
you're going to pay it anyway so you're
going to pay it like it's your debt
because it is your debt now you took it
on so yeah 50 000 bucks a year for three
years you're done and that means you're
on beans and rice rice and beans or 40
000 a year for four years and you're
done
by the way your income is going to
increase dramatically from 80 as you
move on from 24 years old up to an
accounting degree and so all of those
increases do not go to partying or
having fun in new york they go to paying
off daddy's loan that you promised him
you would pay
yeah
did i read your mail all right
he was just running his weekend schedule
through his head right there
just cancelled that vacation that all
inclusive in jamaica that's what just
happened yellow yeah you got to clean
this mess up dude
and the fast deeper you sacrifice the
faster you'll get out that's the formula
and the faster you get out the better
life you're going to have live like no
one else so later you can live and give
like no one else